daran Ravel sports business reporter for
the Action Network last time we had him
on he said don't worry about a potential
lawsuit from Tom Brady with our Tampa
Bay t-shirts and I haven't received a
cease-and-desist yet Darren so we'll
plow ahead we don't have to worry about
that
I saw your article on the draftees at
the NFL Draft can't have any sponsorship
attached to their virtual draft
selection they've done this for years
though haven't they so Wyatt why is the
NFL cracking down here I think it's
because it's over to land there's no one
showing up to any draft location then I
mean we saw when Mariota and Winston
stayed home and then probably got you
know $50,000 each to to do beats by dre
have beats by dre headphones when the
NFL's deals with Bose I think the NFL
has been monitoring it over the years
there there was that moment with Charles
Harris when he had Sasquatch in the
background of the you know I think Rich
Eisen confused him with or or maybe it's
Trey Wingo confusing with Chewbacca
which he wasn't he was the Jack Link's
guy but yes over the years it's kind of
been happening last year ESPN said hey
don't even think about putting a brand
on the camera when the guys coming in
you know we don't want to be taken
advantage of and this year a four-page
memo from the NFL essentially saying
what you can eat drink and wear okay so
the fact that now they can face a fine
they're not an employee yet how does it
not that's the problem it doesn't
specify any type of penalty because
they're not employed by the league they
haven't signed a group licensing
agreement with the Players Association
they don't have a contract with the
league basically what the league is
saying is this is an NFL broadcast
brought to you by our partners espn/abc
and the NFL Network and if you want to
be on it you have to only use our
sponsors and abide by all these rules
now I mean I guess the question is does
does the guy who's in charge of
marketing for for to uh you know I mean
does he do his own stream how valuable
is it to be seen on the broadcast and is
it worth it to take deals from non
sponsors non sponsors are gonna pay you
more Yeah right because they don't have
a deal with the NFL this gets them in so
that's that's a question will over the
next week you know anything happened
where a guy is going to say you know
what I'm gonna do a live cam of mine and
I'm just gonna take all the money and
and the NFL really can't do anything
about it and obviously someone's not
going to be picked because of that you
know we don't like that he's he's going
against us so the NFL really doesn't
have any recourse yeah if I'm one of
these guys a mid first-round or late
first round or a second-round pick and I
have a chance to get product placement
there I go for it you know
I'm not an employee well you know what's
the NFL gonna do yeah yeah people people
will say well if you're a second-round
pick like what's your marketability
remember there are guys who have plenty
of marketability from their college days
where an entire college will watch their
livestream they get so it's not it's not
only you know the first couple guys
there there are guys who come from a big
College you can get a fair amount of
audience by going alone I listen the NFL
has the right to do this I guess if they
go on the broadcast but now what about
Uncle John I mean if if he's six feet
away and he's walking behind the couch
at the right time with a dr. pepper well
you know maybe you do deals like a
family you know there's a lot of in
tennis they always do deals with date
with the Uncle Tony and the people in
the in the box and appointment hey we
didn't do a deal with - oh we did a deal
with his head dad happy to be walking
behind just as the Dolphins were
selecting the pack good stuff Darrin
stay in touch let us know if we're
trouble with Tom Brady I hope I hope
sales are going really well they are
they're brisk it's pre pre lawsuit pre
cease and desist sale going on right now
that's Darren Revell sports business
reporter for the Action Network